翻訳: Erina Chiba
校正: Hiroko Kawano
こんにちは
今日 私は「被災地の復興は日本の復興だ」と
いうようなお話をさせていただこうと思います
それにあたって 僕がどんな活動を
これまでしてきたのか
そしてなぜ そういう考えに至ったのか
という話をしたいと思いますが
今映っている写真は 震災前の私です
私は震災前は 普通の会社員でした
この表情見てください
いい笑顔してるでしょう？
これ女性に囲まれているから
笑顔な訳ではなくて
仕事がすごく楽しくてですね
最高の仲間に恵まれて
非常に楽しく
仕事を毎日していました
ただ ある日を境に
僕の人生が大きく変わりました
それは 2011年3月11日です
この日は 東日本大震災が発災した日です
私はこの時 札幌にいました
札幌で ただただ
自分の故郷である宮城県の町が
津波で襲われる姿を
一晩中ずっとテレビで見ていました
そしてですね 何か役立ちたいと思って
札幌から 週末は仙台に帰ってきて
そして元々会社でお世話になっていた
クライアントさんを中心に
ボランティアであったりとか
顔出しに行ったりとか
そういうことを毎週繰り返していました
その中で あることを考えたんですね
「自分自身は何のために
生きるんだろう」って考えたんです
僕こんなことを
考えたことなかったんです
会社員の頃
毎日仕事も楽しくて
毎日１日１日を楽しく過ごせればいいかなと
そういう風に思っていたんですけど
震災で 被災地に行って
土日はボランティアをして
平日は働いて
その繰り返しの中で
「自分は何のために生きよう？」って
大きな問いにぶつかったんです
それで僕は 本当に悩んで悩んで
１つ決めたことがあります
「今まで自分は 素直に生きてきたかな？」
「もしかして素直に
生きていないかもしれない」
「今 私は もう心も
完全に被災地に行っている」と
だから 想いに素直に生きて
被災地で自分にできることを
やってみようかなと思ったんです
それで 2011年の9月末に会社を辞めて
それで いろんな町
— 被災地ですね
宮城県の被災地を回りました
行政、民間企業、いろんな団体さん
それから個人の方 —
いろんな方に話を聞きながら
「自分は被災地のために
生きたいと思っているけど
何ができるか」ということを
考えていました
そうやって いろんな町を
何回も何十回も回っている中で
出会ったのが 女川町という町でした
女川町はこちらです
女川町は 東日本大震災の
もちろん被災地ではあるんですけども
非常に大きな被害を受けました
町の80％が流失してしまい
そして 約１割の方の命が亡くなりました
この町に 私が飛び込んだ時に
町の方に言われたのは
「なんでもいいから来週 まず手伝ってくれ」と
「来い」と言われたんですね
いろんな町を回ってきて初めてでした
声をかけていただいたのは
だから私はこの町で仕事をしよう
で 自分にできることは
走りながら考えようと思って
まずは女川だということで
女川で活動することを決意しました
それで決意をした時に
色々とこの会社を辞めてから
自分のキャリアを作っていく中で
アドバイスをしてくれた先輩達に
お礼のメールを送ったんです
「女川で活動することを決意しました」と
そうしたらこんなメールが来たんですね
「被災地の復興は日本の復興だ」と
「だからお前がんばれ」
というメールが来たんです
最初 僕はよくわかりませんでした
僕は被災地の —
自分の故郷である
宮城県の被災地の役に立ちたいと思って
会社を辞めて 女川に入った
「日本」って大きすぎるなと思ったんですね
どういうことだろうって考えたんです
それで 少しずつ答えがわかってきたんです
これは日本の人口の長期トレンドです
日本はこれから人口が減っていくっていう
グラフになっていますけれども
今いろんなところで人口減少の話が出ます
被災地どうですかと
震災が来る前から人口は減っていたんです
少子化 高齢化 経済の縮小
そういう課題はもう持っていたんです
そこに津波が来てしまって
多くの方が亡くなって
さらに人口流出が起こり
ある意味 日本で一番そういった社会課題を
抱えている場所になったんです
つまり 被災地というのは
日本の課題先進地だと
だからこそ 先輩はきっと
ここで 女川でお前がやる活動というのは
日本の色々な これから抱える社会課題を
先に取り組んでいく
そして町を作る そして復興していく
そういう場所だから
「日本の復興」という目線を持ってやれ
と言ったんだと思いました
僕はそれでもまだ なんかこう
腹に落ちないというかですね
確かにそうだなと思いながら
他の場所はどうなんだろうと思ったんです
で 僕は縁があって
いろんな海外の経済危機であったりとか
災害危機が起こった町に行きました
そこに行くと やはり
同じようなことが起きているんですね
大きな危機が起こった後に
新しい社会の形であったりとか
もしくは 価値観というものが生まれて
それが国に広がっていくということが
起きているんです
それはなぜかというと
大きな地球の中に社会というものがあって
その中の地域で色々な危機が起こります
そこに対して危機が起きると
そこに住む人
そしてそこを支援しようと集まってくる人たちが
その社会に対して
どのように自分たちが関わるかって
真剣に考えるんですね
そしてその輪が
どんどん どんどん広がって
新しい社会の形とか価値観が生まれて
そして復興が「元に戻す」ではなくて
新しい社会の形につながって
復興が行われていくっていうことが
起きていたんです
僕はなるほどと思ったんですね
日本の今の被災地は
日本の課題先進地であり
そして そこで起こっていることというのは
自分自身がその社会に対してどう関わるか
ということを考えるということなんだと
女川でも同じようなことが起きていたんです
もう一度目を向けると
街で働くこと そして暮らすこと
これはどの街に住んでいても
皆さんが考えること
皆さんがすることです
それにやっぱりプラスアルファで
街の未来に関わるということを考えるんですね
街の方に聞きました
「いやあ でも街の未来に関わる皆さんは
すごいですね」と
「いやあ でも震災があっていろいろと苦労した
色々としんどい思いもしたし
辛い思いもたくさんした」と
「でもこうやって 生き残った以上
街の未来に関わるんだ」と
「震災までこういう動きはなかった」と
「未来を作るんだ」と
そういう風に 街の皆さんは言いました
僕は改めて そういう話をした時に
あ ここで生まれていく
色々な復興の形というのは
本当に日本の復興につながるものが
生まれていくんだなという風に強く感じました
[(英語) コレクティブ・インパクト]
もうそこにはですね —
行政とか民間という壁はないんですね
女川の中でもみんなそれぞれが
街の未来に関わろうとしていて
自分は行政マンだから
自分は企業だからとか
そういうことを一度通り越して
一個人として自分はどうやって
その地域に関わるか
街の未来に関わるのか
ということを考えるんですね
で その中で自分が属している組織が
たまたま行政 もしくは民間、NPO —
そういうものがあって
それぞれの役割というものを
じゃあ どういう役割でやったら
この社会課題を解決できるかなということを
生み出しているっていうのが復興なんです
コレクティブ・インパクトっていう
言葉がありますけど
まさにコレクティブ・インパクトが
起こっているっていうことが
復興だという風に思います
ちょっと抽象度の高い話をしたので
具体的な話をしていきたいと思います
今 女川で 復興過程の中で
女川町民の健康プロジェクトをやっているんです
今 日本の中では
医療費の問題っていうのは
大きな問題になっていますよね
これは 女川も一緒なんです
震災前から生活習慣が悪化していて
そこに震災があって
生活環境が変化して
そして そこに住む人たちの体調が
悪くなりました
さらに 健康診断を受けた後の
指導というものを受けない方が多くて
結果 病気の治療が遅れて
医療費が増えるということが
起きていたんです
日本で起こっていることが
地方でも起きている
先ほど話ししたみたいに
日本のある意味 先進地だと思っています
こういうことが起きている過程の中で
何をしなきゃいけないか
大事なことは
医療費を下げるということは
病気になる前の改善 つまり
予防医療をするということが大事なんですね
ただ予防医療
どうやっていいのかわからないです
行政の方とも話をした時に
どうしよう どうやったら
予防医療できるんだろうと
いや それぞれみんなが
ここに今いろんな人たちが集まって
地域の中の人だけではなく
外の人も集まっている —
それぞれの役割分担の中で
この予防医療に本気で
取り組みましょうっていう話をしました
そして 予防医療の専門性を持っている企業と
それから 住民の情報をよく知っている行政
そして そういった公と民をつなぐNPO
その三者がパートナーになって
一緒にそれぞれの役割の元
この復興過程の中で
予防医療のいろんな取り組みをやっていこうと
予防医療の専門性を持っている企業さんは
ここでやっている取り組みが
成功すれば日本に広がると
それは商品なのか サービスなのか
まだわからないけれども
ここから ここでやることが
結果 日本の予防医療につながると
信じていると言ってくれました
こういうことなんですね
そこのパートナーの中に
さらにいろんな企業さんであったりとか
大学さんであったり NPOさんが
参画できるように開いています
さらに アメリカで
すでに予防医療に取り組んでいる
NPOとも連携をして
そして今 町民の方々の健康を
作ろうというような事業をやっています
これ 行政の方が言いました
「震災が起きなければ
こんなこと絶対に起きなかった」と
震災[復興]というものは
先ほど話しをしたみたいに
元に戻すことではないんですね
新しく 新しいものを生み出すことなんです
まさに こういう新しい動きが
こうやって女川の中で生まれて
そしてそこから日本に広がろう
というふうにしています
最後に 私が地域で活動するときに
大事にしている言葉をご紹介して
終わりにしたいと思います
この方は 二宮尊徳という方です
二宮金次郎といったほうが
わかりやすいかもしれません
彼は 江戸時代に
荒廃した村を 農業を通して
再生させてきた人です
彼はいろんな村に行って
荒廃した土地を 地元の人たちと一緒に
もう一度農地として耕して
そして 再生させて
街として成り立たせるということを
やっていたんですね
彼のところにいろんな方が訪ねてくるんです
彼は何を言ったか その方々に
こんなことを言ったんです
「一村を救出できる方法は
一国を救出できる」と
「その原理は同じなんだ」という
話をしたんですね
まさに今 女川でやっていること
それがもしかして国を救えるかもしれない
僕はこの言葉はすごく大事にしています
あわせて ある村で
その再生を取り組んでいるときに
二宮尊徳が言った言葉があります
「目の前の仕事に全力を尽くせ —
それがいずれ 全国の役に立つ」と
僕は改めてこの言葉を見て 読んで
女川で全力を尽くして
そしてそこから全国を救う役に立つようなことを
色々と生み出していければなと思っています
「女川の復興は日本の復興」
僕自身は そのように信じて
今 活動しています
僕には たくさんの仲間がいます
この写真は 女川町のある飲み屋さんで
撮った写真ですけども
この中には
町長もいれば 行政の方もいれば
地元の民間企業の方もいれば
グローバルに展開する企業の方もいます
そういういろんな人たちが
いろんな意見をぶつけ合って
そしてそれぞれの役割の元で
新しいことを発想して
想像して復興を成し得ていく
それが今 東北
いろんなところで起こっています
女川でも起こっています
僕は こういった仲間たちと一緒に
女川の復興を通して
日本の復興に役立ちたいなと
思っております
私の思いは 全て込めて
ここで話した形になりますので
ぜひ女川で成功させて
日本に広げていきたいというふうに
思っております
ありがとうございました
（拍手）